greetings from podcast Ville it's
Tuesday the 25th of June get your [ __ ]
together the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you by and I tend to
reintroduce him back to the show then
Sarah watches I still have my beautiful
platinum watch from Vince arrow
I changed the band on it to even make it
classy because let me tell you something
a wristwatch is a personal style
statement but Sarah listening has been
solid and it has fallen down I wear it
on stage seeing what time it is and it's
never let me down so elevate your game
we've been Saros handcrafted luxury
watches at an unbeatable price then
sarah provides bold timepieces always
putting quality above all else
now you get your Vince arrow watch today
with a special offer for the church
family all right you ready go to bizarro
watches comm grab a pen go to Vince
arrow watches VI n CER o watches comm
and enter code Church CH you are CH at
checkout and I'm gonna give you 15% or
if you order it with worldwide again
worldwide shipping is always free
that's vince arrow watches comm promo
code church vince arrow VI NC VI and CEO
watches dot-com promo code church and as
always free shipping is free worldwide
on the arm
that's how Vince Errol does it because
they believe in their product number two
I want to thank CBD lye and why because
they've made getting help from the CBD
products that much easier if uncle
Joey's telling you CBD line is the goods
it's the goods you lucky for you mother
[ __ ] as I found CBD Lyon alright it
comes in vape cartridges shadow tincture
is whatever you need CBD lions got your
coverage go to see me the alarm right
now calm
and add them and check out their third
party lab results you see something you
like whether it's a 10
to the gummies the shadow go for it
because the church family gets 20% off
at checkout when you press in church I
also like that listen this Wally is cuz
I was there as most he ever found out
the hard way getting into debt is easy
very easy you come out of college they
give you all these credit cards you
start meeting the girl gold at dinner
you think this don't add up but it gets
hard especially if your FICO score isn't
that great thankfully now there's an
upstart calm the revolutionary lending
platform that knows you're more than
just a credit score and office your
smallest interest rates to help you pay
off high-interest credit card debt if I
were to had these guys 20 years ago my
credit score would have been completely
different today I had to work together
what I was but upstart will help you
because they go beyond the traditional
FICO score when assessing your credit
worthiness do me a favor see why upstart
is ranked number one again number one in
their category with over 300 businesses
on Trustpilot and Harry the upstart com
slash Church Church CH you are CH and
find out how low your upstart rate is
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes and it will not affect your
credit that's upstart com slash Church I
want to thank upstart
I want to thank CBD Lyon and I want to
thank Mancera watches dog but most
importantly I want to thank you animals
for being our family and listening to
Lee kick this [ __ ] meal pound
pound pound
what's up pearls cackle today I love
Judas preyas I love Judith grace but all
my [ __ ] on I seen them open up with
this song once and it blew me to [ __ ]
away on this tour oh there's gotta be
like 83 or something 83 84
they blew me the [ __ ] out of it they
came out to silence no motorcycle and
you just heard that little Club Glenn
Tipton guitar was like Jesus Christ
what's up brother dude it's an honor
it's an honor for you to be I saw you
the other night
I've been thinking a lot of body and I
keep seeing and forgettin cuz I'm at the
store and comedy business not on podcast
business so when I get in the car and I
slammed the door and I'm driving up
world K I'm like [ __ ] I didn't ask her
when he was available I saw you the
other night briefly and I was gonna get
right back to you in there and you know
how the stories oh yeah you just
disappear into a [ __ ] crowd and there
you go
you'll know you're gonna see him anymore
like Paulie well I mean I didn't you
know I know you've got a thousand people
hitting you have to be on it I'm shy
wasn't I'm just you know I don't ask
it's just cuz I'd get I don't want to be
a pain in the ass no it's weird I always
like finding a hook for people that's
what people understand like some kind of
some opening to me knowing I want to be
in the Python you know what I have you
on the podcast also let me wait through
a hook there's gotta be something a
topic something happens in your life
something happens at the store a
generality sure can we get you in then
I'd rather get you down the hook and
just walk in and not [ __ ] to have
anything to talk to you about yeah I
mean I get it you know but still I mean
I've wanted to come on for a long time
and yeah it's you know it's the weirdest
thing I like to have people on the show
that I know yeah for sure they'll have
some sort of relationship with or I know
a lot about it's the people who hit you
up that you don't know at all but you
just don't know these people like I want
to be on your show all the [ __ ] you
you know I don't even know you so it
wouldn't work we'd have to play catch-up
for an hour before the show started brot
and then do the [ __ ] shell most
people have a background this I like all
I need is one thing to relate to and we
could spread out the podcast you know so
I'm sorry if it took long to get to you
oh no I mean the reason why I wanted to
be on is because you keep it real you
know you're now see you gonna do well
there's a lot of people who don't what
I'll see you at though I mean I cannot
I'm old or any you know what I want to
come in here and [ __ ] you know yes
that was at the park with my daughter
I'm sitting there
and my daughter's playing with some girl
and the husband is talking to my wife
and no the guy's wife is standing there
staring off and the [ __ ] Jupiter
whatever and was sitting there having a
good time and the [ __ ] guy walks on
here's some [ __ ] far and I don't know
and he's coming in with a white wife and
they started yakking and talking and and
he's loud he's obnoxious the guy and
he's like I wish they sold beer at the
park
you know what are you [ __ ] talking
about shut the [ __ ] up
he said I'd like to tie one on at the
park you know I just I didn't know my
[ __ ] point was but it's just weird
how you know was gonna work on the
podcast and you know was not oh sure you
know you don't want to have a bad
podcast you at least people want them to
get something out of the podcast my
point was about that guy was that he was
the biggest fake right he was a typical
you know Studio City fake [ __ ] bad
the wife had the yoga bag so everybody
knows she went to yoga you know they had
the crib out loud he talked about
auditions and the new movie he got in
Japan you know people don't do that
that's not how I grew up with people
shut up [ __ ] up
I remember when they went away I finally
looked at my wife Amway thank God that
[ __ ] got the [ __ ] away from me
my wife came you look like what I don't
even want to hear that [ __ ] rocks [ __ ]
Sunday save it somewhere else you know I
can't be that type of person well that's
why I love you I can never be I could
never Oh ones credit cards and being a
vacation and jump up and down and tell
people and having a good time you all
[ __ ] twenty thousand on credit cards
well good time to jab you know how their
eat and everything you're eating you're
looking at like a [ __ ] bomb P you
know people who uh you know drive a car
to impress people I'm over that [ __ ]
like I'm over all that [ __ ] you know
like I was over that when I was 21 right
you know so the only way I know how to
treat people it's just you know the way
is supposed to be tree
nice and simple yes not a hug if I like
yeah I like it if I don't like to keep
[ __ ] walking you know
why [ __ ] with people why give somebody a
false whatever you might not like
somebody or something might say you know
the the greatest thing about it is that
we're all not perfect and we all don't
have to like the same movies and we all
wait to have to like the same music
that's the best thing about being an
American I think I'll be then who's
playing later they have that option
because in some places you don't well no
we all have that option oh you don't
like that person you you were raised
well enough not to tell that person you
don't like them but you avoid them but I
find the older I get it's harder for me
to hold when I don't like someone in if
I don't like someone they know well they
know because of your body language yeah
absolutely little [ __ ] like that but I
don't have the heart to tell somebody
less never know like unless they're
getting on my last function ever I'm
trying to have a good time and you have
to tell people exactly but I wouldn't
want somebody to tell me that
enlightening so I use it the same way
you know it somebody's in your corner
we're not dumb you know we're not
they're up in 10 anymore you know when
somebody lives and breathes for you and
you knowing somebody's an acquaintance
absolutely there's a big [ __ ]
difference when you know that person
will live and die for me but that
person's just a hello goodbye good to
see you what are we doing lunch
Critz get-together I love your podcast
you know when you're gonna have me and
I'm gonna have you on yours
all that [ __ ] people want to hear out
here and it's kind of weird like my my
my go-to is always a guy I don't talk I
try to say hi and get out of the way
like I don't I don't really stick around
but it is kind of weird sometimes when
you feel like you're putting out like
hey I'm not really a huge fan of you and
they just stick around and like they
won't they can't take a hint
like I I never want to be an issue I
never want to have someone oh he's
overstaying his welcome so the guy but
there's some people who do the opposite
of that well they just don't get social
cues like someone has their back turned
to you they don't want to talk to you
right it's pretty good I mean
I don't know I was raised just to be
straightforward people yeah make you
listen you got a while to get a piece of
[ __ ]
you got a lie to get a job you know I'm
saying I'm like yeah yeah I gotta move
the moon before all the time I was just
there last week you know what happened
to get a job you know we all first start
dating the girl or girls for women gonna
listening but you start dating the guy
or sudden you love the Boston Red Sox -
you know no I'm not it gives you
permission to go buy a hat to wear the
game with us to look like a [ __ ]
idiot
take the [ __ ] hat off you like hockey
and [ __ ] ice skating you know it's
the same thing we do you know the first
day you like cats I love cats oh yeah
like cats you'll kick that [ __ ]
she's gone around but we all have to
tell those little white lies I get that
but to be dishonest with somebody like
the guys I have respect for the most and
comi his Booker's were the people who
look me in the face and said listen you
do blue or the Michael all right as a
feature act get some credits and call me
back which I am very tight with those
people today because they told me what
their business called for and what I
needed to be the work in that business
it's the people come up to you at the
store go hey do you want to go to my
club in San Antonio and you're like yeah
send the tape and I'll get you in and
you send the tape man I never pick up
the phone then you don't see him for
three or four years I'm gonna see him
and it'll talk to you they give you some
excuse hard now got any messages I never
got your tape and then one day you get
booked on Comedy Central premium blend
and they put it off for me
hey Joey yeah are you doing well it's
great to see all your success and you
sit there and you want to smack them say
something because now I have people
contacting me that would not even answer
the phone oh yeah it's very funny and
they're happy for my success they're all
happy I look at them I'm gonna take
their [ __ ] envelope I don't give a
[ __ ] don't even have your attack we all
know what this is we all know what this
is this is no likey nobody like nobody
we all know what this is okay you come
in you watch the first show for ten
minutes
you wait till after the show you told me
I had a sensational set that you liked a
particular joke and then I don't see you
the rest of the weekend you make your
money and I make mine that's exactly
what we are when you understand that it
makes everything when you understand
exactly what position you're in it makes
your life your career that much easier
so you know you were working a
restaurant and you're a dishwasher
and you're like I know how to make this
give this place and you look to the
owner yelling why don't you do a happy
hour and talk to us and he looks at you
like you're you got three [ __ ] heads
I go on the back kitchen all right
you're a [ __ ] we thought you were
dishwasher you know it's kind of the
same [ __ ] thing
you know well I just wish you know like
Adam at the Comedy Store when he
showcased me he was like dude I know
everyone's telling me I got a pass you
because they love you and you've been up
here forever but if you don't do well I
can't pass you and that's great Adam was
very very very honest oh I love Adam has
been thrown I give my props to Adam I'm
slew in a big way he's done for people
Adam as the talent coordinator at The
Comedy Store before we started the
podcast and I were talking about the
comedy stole I first got and if you knew
what the county straw was then and you
know what the comedy stories now it's
still a [ __ ] major art hub and Los
Angeles on the west coast but now it has
rules that are enforced
there was always loose rules Mitsy
always had rules for certain people
certain people get away with some things
well Lee could get away when I can't get
away with him Earl could get away when I
can you know say oh absolutely
with Adam it's pretty blatant and I've
heard Adam be honest with people like
one of my first two months of the store
I was just standing by the wall and
there was no fool comics and he was
bugging Adam and Adam answer them like
listen there's just no room for here in
this few wants she under acts Baba
my heart sunk for the guy sir heart sunk
for the guy he's been around for thirty
years great comic movies the whole thing
but it's true you're 60 and there's no
room for you here anymore oh yeah
it's time to move on at some other
talent coordinator we'll go ahead call
him for spots on Monday and pass the
buck
oh so Tommy would have done right pass
the buck that took all the Avena or what
I really appreciate that and had a
missed turned that place around the
first town coordinator when I was there
also helped my career immensely he broke
it down well and I loved him I still
talk to him on Facebook he was in Africa
on a [ __ ] Linscott day Scott they did
not played Scott they knew what the time
it was now there he knew that the place
is run he kept a little bit of semblance
and he would give you advice you want
more spots don't call him for Thursday
Friday Saturday let Mitch you know
you're available to hope on the weekend
you're like oh I get it now he would
tell you little things he would talk to
you at night he would still be there at
10:00 you know right which free that's
very rare that I gotta take my hats off
to Adam tommy was there to steal Wow
yeah at night but the guys before Tommy
the town coordinators they really didn't
hang till after 8:30 8:30 they would be
there having a drink and they [ __ ]
waved and in that really relationship
from agents didn't have relationship
management the guy have to [ __ ] my
guy Scott day that left was there and I
missed a movie cuz he didn't really like
me and paramount called for me for an
audition they know they got a hold of me
he never said none to me I found that
years later from battle oh yeah they
hired me for something different and
said we wanted you for this
we called the store three times and left
messages we didn't know how they're
gonna hold it so there was a lot of that
[ __ ] going on or I don't like girl Mitzi
pasture but I'm gonna know a favor all
right so when Willie Morris Paul
look around Skakel I tell him I don't
know what his number is I don't even
know what he's talking about how I think
I know the answer but I'd be interested
to hear to you guys talk about it how
much of this business is fair and how
much of it is stuff like that just who
who likes you like is there any fairness
in this business yourself throw a simple
question is life fair not really good
why we're [ __ ] commie be yeah I'm in
this van and also what you consider a
fair nothing is fair and that's what you
consider fair and in this business
you're gonna see a lot of different
things like at any business you know
it's like when you work for a large
company you quit high school while you
were in high school you work for a
[ __ ] lumberyard okay you start in the
back they promote you to the cutter make
sure you know you're loaded next to know
you're a driver
next thing you know you're running the
place in the back you're actually
general manager he talked you out of
college to be his general manager the
thing then another guy leaves now they
move you inside and you're a [ __ ] you
know the whole business from the inside
the outside now you're the general
manager there for 20 years and the
owners about to retire who's gonna be
the [ __ ] number one man you hopefully
but guess what happens he's got a son
right who's a [ __ ] and he went to
Harvard and you know many times in the
20 years of his existence he walked into
that lumberyard 3-0 twice to pick up
checks to go out down on the shore with
his buddies and now that [ __ ]
jerk-off is gonna come in and be your
boss and not only is it gonna be your
boss he's gonna come in and change the
system around because he's a college boy
he learned by laps and [ __ ] the
people who deliver for you you know uber
delivers and he's gonna cut the lumber
yards over each aisle of his [ __ ]
plywood it's amazing
so is that fair that you gave your whole
life for a company and now this this guy
had a much son and now he comes in never
spent the summer with you never loaded a
roof with you in the summers never came
in on the summer jobs is that fair
really I'll write that you know I'm not
saying nothing racist here not saying
nothing racist me and enough Skakel
de-aged
we've been working the streets are away
for 10 [ __ ] years and San Francisco
okay Louie is Puerto Rican he just
graduated Emison with a social social
economics degree and the [ __ ] didn't a
law degree all of a sudden you come in
me and Earl put transfers to go to Miami
huh guess who gets the job you because
you're Spanish and they need one extra
guy down there so me and I'll schedule
gotta keep sucking dick in Sacramento
smoking meth with a bunch of Dan you
like me like ether enough you follow me
so everybody catches a break I saw at
the end of the day I gotta explain some
to you before you get negativity in your
mind even an old dog gets a warm spot on
the sidewalk at the end of the day it
all [ __ ] evens out I think so you're
gonna be shafted in this [ __ ] life
you have to accept that you're gonna be
[ __ ] in this life you go home and
drink and jump up and down but
eventually some reason to be in your
position and you're gonna [ __ ] them and
all the evens out
so all that bitching and crying you did
when you were 31 now you got [ __ ] you
deserve it and you went to brown for
four years my genius and you a part of
the chess club that all goes out the
window because it all evens out for
years I cried them sitting here telling
you what there was none to cry about
there was nothing at all to cry about
this whole thing evens out you just have
to give it a shot and keep trying you
know there's gonna be those auditions
you go in eight times then make you take
your shirt off then make you dance
Demi come in early in the morning and
read from the stars of the movie and
you're not gonna get it they're gonna go
with a penguin
you're gonna be there all week long or
we fall three times with the same three
white guys the same three white guys
just by episodes of Modern Family this
could change your life forever get you a
theatrical agent get your spots in town
you going Monday they love you you're
going to z' day for producers they love
you you're going Wednesday for network
and producers they love you same three
guys me you and her all three days you
wish arrow gets hit by a bullet and
enjoy it is we get hit by a bolt of
lightning you would give up your [ __ ]
pension to the Jewish gods that's how
you feel after the third day that you
see your own Skakel and [ __ ] Jodie is
the same audition and they're both going
for the same thing you're going guess
what these [ __ ] do to you they
make you come back again on Thursday and
they make you reread the [ __ ] thing
and then guess what they do to your
Friday
they make you come down again and read
with the star of the [ __ ] TV show at
10:00 in the morning so now the rest of
the [ __ ] day you can't even [ __ ]
focus from what's going on you're
thinking about you heard Earl he sounded
better in the audition and Joey Diaz
brought in a white shirt and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] up and you're thinking all this
now it's Saturday morning your
girlfriend wants to suck your dick but
you can't let her suck your dick cause
all you're thinking about is role and
how it's gonna change your [ __ ] life
and how you're gonna get spots now and
people gonna respect you and you're
gonna get eight episodes our modern
[ __ ] family and Sunday when you go to
your parents house you know you want to
hear their [ __ ] voice feed you the
potato pancakes and they're lighting
candles on the yarmulke whatever you
[ __ ] blowing them out [ __ ] you you
can't even focus and Monday morning at
eight [ __ ] 30 the first call is your
agent you're about the answer you got
the [ __ ] roll you pick up the phone
then go hey we just want to tell you
they went with somebody else and you go
goddamnit
it was Joey cuz of the white shirt
they're like no they changed their mind
they went with a black guy and you're
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about is
that worse that it's not it's I'm not
saying a black guy could say Chinese
well I understand it change it to a
woman they do
that to you but then one day guess what
we're sitting in this room no Skakel
father one night Steven Spielberg walks
into the school store and falls in love
where wants to write this story oh it's
possible [ __ ] page blockbuster 85
billion dollar budget and one day your
phone rings and it's Earl and he goes I
want you to shoot 11 days up my boy and
you sit there go do outdoor edition
no no just got a wardrobe get fitted you
start next Monday and that's how life
works and remember that TV show that you
read for Modern Family right well the
season you were gonna read for it wasn't
hot no more the gay guy got shot during
the off season have to show no more so
you're all that panicking and crying you
did and what I'd stardom you built up in
your head what's for nothing well how
how hard is it then - when the good
things happen how hard is it for you to
keep a keep a level head and not get too
excited because eventually it's gonna
end right like do you have to worry
about that when I got here I saw a very
important lesson I saw a man by the name
of Tom Rhodes with long hair at the
improv is showing just been canceled and
you know look on his face like his show
had been canceled well he went up on
stage and rock the mic and you like that
moment I said no matter what you do you
always be a stand-up they can't take
that away from you right there at that
moment it was my seventh time a year of
doing comedy baby he is a dong comedy I
realized at that moment that we were
something special because we did comedy
if i [ __ ] jesse some a lot up the ass i
won't ever work on TV they'll never hire
me on TV no more they find the picture
me with Jesse [ __ ] them with a rope
around his neck wearing the trump hat on
I'm not working ever again you don't
know that I don't know I know that for a
fact in today's climate well I got a
movie no voiceover you got a better
chance to [ __ ] hit
[ __ ] judge wacko wacko whack but but
I can always do stand-up the small clubs
and clothes at the story about the time
when I [ __ ] Jess it's not up the ass and
I will let do it she doesn't always make
a living and have a t-shirt with Jesse
with it huh
you understand me so right there I pull
it I figure that out I figured out and
then over the years I saw people who got
built up to be stars fell apart and they
could nail oh oh yeah then I figured out
that this business is about hard work
and stay in here
I believe that staying here staying here
and now your comedy shifts now your life
shifts when you first started calmly you
bombed nine times on every ten sets oh
yeah I left the 90 days you bomb eight
times after every and so on and so on
and the more you do it the less the
bombings come
well now the percentage has changed for
you once you get the hell away in the
major leagues and once read something
that who did uh who's the bald guy
that's good-looking that does the car
movies well Vince these let's diesel
said something interesting was I I'm
gonna stop I just stayed here I guess
when he won't be eating with you with
nine people three years three of them
left you know he can't plug him so two
more years went by to walk I'm married
and left he hung it that's it that's it
this is what the what did you start
comedy oh so long ago I literally don't
remember but I obviously 99 ish
here and that yeah you know I but I went
to this store you originally from where
a Bel Air California no sure you went to
high school with Notre Dame High in the
valley
no yes so college I didn't really I am
see the junior college in Santa Monica I
never really finished it just wasn't for
me
what did you do at that time it became a
fitness trainer I used to be a lot
bigger and then I knew I did I wanted to
do comedy I just
when did you know you wanted to do
comedy what 80 I'll be the fourth great
play I did when I got a big laugh a sec
I'll never forget it's probably the most
genuine laugh I've ever gotten
it was just a one line in the fourth
grade play and I just I want that now as
an adult did you call him by an album
method you know on the family was like
my first comedy inspiration you know it
wasn't traditional stand-up you know I
loved what Archie Bunker not what he was
saying but how he would say it and still
be likable and then there was a show
called the white shadow tremendous which
was like an ensemble all in the family
it was a white basketball coach with an
all-black team on CBS on Monday nights
yeah at like nine o'clock it was an hour
dramedy it was one of the first he was
great he came to the sport one day
ken raised the coach Ken Howard ken
Howard when I first got that sugar and
eighty times I was ready to give him a
hand job because I loved the white
shadow
you know how old are you if we don't
lift it so 50 so you grew up in a time
when Archie Bunker to me was the people
I was living right right so to me it was
just another day
sure Harris I never looking as an
ng-show that's the way you know I had
friends you went to the house when that
dad walked in on his jacket
they would just walk up to you and look
at you to say get the [ __ ] out of my
chair and you accept it you didn't run
home and tell your mom mr. scapegoat
told me to get the [ __ ] out of his chair
and you sat the other chain you watch TV
with them you know one of the best
episodes I think they ever saw of him
especially with comedic timing was what
the Puerto Rican found the wallet Oh God
in this cab was I think Sammy Davis left
on Cissy left his briefcase briefcase
but there was something with the Puerto
Rican came through from me no it was
Chico in the man Freddie prize no no it
wasn't Freddie Prinze it was the guy
that play
the Spanish guy in fact that guy made a
career out of play actor called a staff
of the Sun and the one no boy Ricans in
my house so I was talking about the guy
Hector Hector did samplings son Hector
did the Puerto Rican and on the family
Hector also was in a few episodes of
Miami rice at the beginning at the
[ __ ] actor rocked but in that episode
he comes to the door they invite him in
and he looks at me he goes either don't
just stand there or from something to
drink and she goes wrong with you like I
got milk I got beer and he goes I don't
know he goes or from whatever Puerto
Ricans like friendly to the side also he
looked so straight to facing us how
about some pineapple juice and I I don't
know how old I was
I [ __ ] lost it there was two parts in
television history that I lost it I
watched them live I'm very fortunate the
Friday and I would read Fox when he went
into the courtroom and he was like it
was good oh he's bigger than me and
there's no [ __ ] a movie that was MBC
poor I know it was they was sampling
southern ain't o'clock and Chico on the
man of 8:30 and if you were anything of
a comedy fan like I was for me it
started with JJ Walker oh sure it was
good times
then there was it was white shadow and
then I was a basketball player right so
I related to white shadow you know then
it was the NBC lineup which was [ __ ]
deadly comedy right and if you paid
attention it went on to become Miami
Vice
O'Reilly is at nine and crime story oh I
love that I had when they had nude rice
clay I try and turn so many people on
the crime story and it was only around
for two seasons but to seize it's
Michael Mann he had two shows on
back-to-back write crime story was his
yeah crime story it
Miami Vice was his but that's when Vice
kind of started going downhill is when
he left to do crime story he left it to
other people and isn't Zito left Miami
Vice and midway through the season three
and it was never the same because he was
the comic relief with swai tech so you
know they were like the two detectives
who would like Zeno died from the OD is
it yeah the they put a box in the soda
and the guy in that episode was Pepe
Serna y'all he's legendary I had to be
certain it was who got his arm cut off
and in Scarface yeah and I did a movie
with him and when they were talking like
oh how was that sainted there's no no
but they had two arms and I took one and
I he made it for 75 grand oh the one arm
from the from there
yeah Pepe sure know who else is in that
damn Miss OH
I mean uh mark Breeland was the box
Breeland Jesus Christ I mean I'm like a
new Miami Vice is probably my favorite
show of all time seems serious oh yeah I
mean it took me three or four episodes
no the pilot came on September of 84
which wasn't like on the Sunday night it
was a Sunday like two-hour premiere and
I was at a bar called Gregory's
seven-day weekend
heavy duty ba bottles at the door
you know [ __ ] the law allowed jukebox
and for that for some reason cocaine was
a long time line cocaine was an all-time
high
people would get live for days it was
September of 84 and people who were
snorting with both [ __ ] hands my
neighborhood everybody was on coke the
whole country was pretty much on coke
and all of a sudden they released this
show called Miami Vice about these two
cops in Miami
another chasing the the one cop was
chasing the guy named Calderon down to
Miami and he teams up with Crockett when
his tart with his partner who was played
by Jimmy Smits but and the pilot is
blown up yeah so now Crockett needs a
partner
you know Tootie the black girl oh yeah
she was a waitress at the store really
Pro you have no [ __ ] idea how much
history the store has to let so one
night I'm sitting there in the front and
Chewie the ex doorman is talking to a
black guy the black guy happened to be
the black guy in Forrest Gump oh yeah
some guy I guess so tell me is they
alright because he was also in the Great
Santini ok so that black dude isn't a
pilot of Miami Vice
he plays Calderon middle man and there's
a scene where he him in cropper they're
working together this is a legendary
night for a gal like me like I've had
many legendary nights at the store but
on this particular night he was standing
six feet from me and I didn't know how
to approach him
there was no no way in my world I was
gonna approach this guy he did not know
how big of a fan while I was as what's
his name not middle - I was gonna say as
a machete hold on
Mickelson williams michael t michael
soon Mykelti will help oh yeah Williams
and Mykelti Williamson there you go so
but Kelty williamson has a live in miami
he meets Don Johnson first with the
other guy by himself so I he meets Don
and then he do you see him believe a
barbecue place and he gets in this
[ __ ] beautiful Mercedes Benz and
before he gets in he wipes the side
panel with his suit and he gets in and
he's about to get to a barbecue and Don
John sits convertible Don Johnson jumps
in the 450s I'll see it smacks the
chicken out of his hand and the guy just
looks at Don Johnson and he goes
barbecue on my upholstery I've killed
for less and he's gonna save me the
tough talk Leon his name was Leah
so progresses by robe on because he's
getting closer to me and I don't know
where he goes you have a good set
tonight I watch Chuy said to go on and
watch it you were gonna be good
and he I said Michael T like I know
y'all and I looked it was straight in
the face and I go barbecue on my
upholstery uh I've killed for less and
he looked at me oh when I go Miami Vice
84 he goes oh [ __ ] I know that's how
long I've been a fan of yours you know
and so he proceeded to tell me he
auditioned for it and didn't hear
anything and one night he would look to
Atami store and the black ground to
Comedy Store had just done trading
[ __ ] places no 48 hours right
hoodie is the chick that Eddie Murphy
meets at the bar and 48 hours when he
goes up to Nick Nolte and goes come on
dawg I just need an hour to get me some
Mogambo and Nick no what are you talking
about he was like you know some Mogambo
some trim it's it's Tunney and then on
the way out he give us her money and she
goes I'm not a pro when you get out look
me up and we'll date I had a nice time
with you that's the first time you ever
see Twitty when she shot that she was at
The Comedy Store Eddie Murphy met her at
the economy still oh wow and gave her a
roll of that so now Michael T goes up to
the comedy store meat study and in the
process of dating she gets the audition
for Miami Vice they both get it Liam
gets killed in the pilot yeah he's the
car and what she ended up becoming a
waitress
that's why it was cool to be a waitress
after the word got out that waitresses
were born at the Comedy Store now
they're doing TV series a bunch of
aspiring actresses started getting
waitressing jobs so it's crazy
does it make sense a lot of people go in
there why not yeah like that even today
years ago Ivana Chubbuck was a great
acting school but once Halle Berry and
the white chick won the Academy Award
back-to-back they were both her students
our money went up to the roof and went
from 200 a [ __ ] month or 255 and now
every hot chick in town was signing up
van a java class one over that phone
what's the hot white chick six-foot-tall
aha Chili's they always say Ron yes
originally it was surely Halle Berry
Academy would would is back-to-back
little bonus in my acting class women's
squad here to get into that class and if
you got into the Thursday night class
and advantage topic agents would be up
there giving out [ __ ] checks so you
had to work yourself up into the
Thursday night class how we got on this
forgive me I know no please I mean Miami
but I could talk for hours on Miami Vice
what made you get into Miami Vice did
you see the pilot oh yeah I saw I was
into Dallas at the time you know jr. and
all that and I just wanted the name last
landing type of [ __ ]
Gary shackling right Wednesday nights
was Knots Landing I think Thursday was
Dallas and Wednesdays I stayed in had a
night off from coke well I think it was
a shitty ladies night is something that
was that I wasn't into it I mean Friday
was Dallas so that's why I was a big
palaces Friday Miami it was Dallas dukes
of hazzard on channel 2 and then that's
why I was a big deal at Miami Vice was
such a big show because it was directly
taking on those two shows so but I just
love the show and like you know Gregory
Sierra was the original captain on Miami
Vice and he lived here and he didn't
want to go to Miami he wanted more money
for the plane tickets and stuff so they
just killed him they blew him up not
Jimmy Smits Gregory Sierra he died on
the like the third episode and he got on
the boat yeah that's what I'm talking
about
that no he was a Spanish guy no that was
Jimmy Smits died yes Jimmy Smits died
when he got blown up by the car but then
an episode three they send the Colombian
Argentinian the Argentinian in episode 3
to go shoot a hit list Crockett Tubbs
and they had the captain on there so
when the captain went to save Crockett
the guy was a 9 in a watchtower and he
killed that guy yeah Gregory Sierra is
the guy who I'm talking about was in
Chico in the man okay look up Gregory
Sierra IMDB and I was said that guy was
too token [ __ ] Spanish guy here and
the seventies lady that guy ain't worth
ten million dollars out of the whole the
[ __ ] is is he dead no I think he's a
while but can you imagine if he stayed
on vice like he just didn't want to
travel and he saw I think he hit him up
for more money says he's still alive
he's still he's still working yeah he
took a long time off actually but I just
did something last year what TV credits
oh my god probably let's take an hour to
read TV credits yeah oh my god oh wow
yeah he started working in the 60s or
early 70s
yeah 69 it takes a thief tremendous mod
squad I recognize squad was another
great show on ABC The Flying Nun Trebek
this who's hidden beneath the Planet of
the Apes yeah this guy's 'never it was
in the Bill Cosby Show watch out he was
a [ __ ] impossible all the family what
year was that do you think cuz that one
right now I'm in 72 you go who's in the
Waltons all in the family 73 Oh Joe who
the [ __ ] you think you're dealing with
Sanford and Son
75 y5o told you every Columbo every hit
show he was the token Spanish guy yeah
and that's only now only over 74 he
didn't stop working Gunsmoke Sanford and
Son 75 of the sample the son um 12 yeah
I do not want no Puerto Ricans in my
house Barney Miller he did 35 episodes
I'm telling you dog I think he was a
sheriff or not a sheriff hello a cop or
detective in the photo
heaven fish yeah this is crazy I looked
up to that guy growing up I was like
that's a guy yeah like how much work
does he get as a Spanish guy soap you
know so for such a good show I'm telling
you ask for the time like that's why I
love all these shows like so on the
family white shadow this is when there's
only three networks no snow Showtime or
HBO s believe it or not you're looking
at a guy that really really
I think if there was a show that broke
me before the honeymoon the show
honeymooners broke me that broke me
comically sampling the Sun and Archie
Bunker were great the honeymooners took
that Benny Hill my combination was Benny
Hill the honeymooners came on 11 odd
couple yeah sponge Twilight came out at
midnight you can't beat that you just
stayed in just to watch that [ __ ] that's
weird but I always felt that Greece here
was one of those guys that you know he
just looked up to you had if you watch
television I just told you I just knew
who he was on two or three shows I
didn't know he was and all that always a
lot more than I anticipated he worked
constantly guys like they had no Spanish
people that fit his MO he's like the
true definition of character you don't
know his name
they're like I know that face and like
that episode of the white shadow where
the Russian kid tries to defect from the
basketball team that guy for kid is
named John something he's his IMDB page
just to be a 500 credits he said he's
like white guy he could play Polish
Russian Jewish
he works constantly to this day did you
act a lot uh not really up until
recently like I was in I'm dying up here
just playing a bitter late-night comic
so I really wasn't acting but you know
no I was too scared I was trying to get
into comedy and let alone start acting
and what voice what was the first place
you got on the stage at Los Angeles
Comedy Store you went up Dan did the
three minutes and I'll be completely
honest with you I paid Dave Tyree to
write for me because I saw him open up
for Eddie Griffin yes and it was in the
main room and I was just like wow this
guy's pretty dirty you had a bit about
bringing a girl it's like feeding a
horse and that's like that's the kind of
humor I want to do as I paid him and I
still have the jokes he gave me they
were all still
jokes like I didn't know any better back
then but they were all like you know hey
I bought a liquor cabinet I didn't even
drink you know he's just like I heard
that in a joke book before so he kind of
ripped me off but like serves me right
you know I should have just gone out
there and talked about you know growing
up in bel-air it's a weird angle to have
most comics rapport or you know come
from a poor background I was lucky
enough to come from a semi not wealthy
but you know would you parents do if you
don't mind me asking oh no no my dad he
was like MacGyver you would get the
reference cuz I told
jessimae Peluso that today and she's
like who's MacGyver he was like good at
everything
scratch golfer had the worst golf swing
you've ever seen but he could have been
a pro he's on the cover of Life magazine
and I think 64 for killing a whale how
do they put money either back how do you
feed you guys his his dad in the
depression would drive by oil refineries
and he would see that they would just
throw away their waste and he go into
all these refineries and who can I have
your waste they thought you're crazy
should go take it and he turned it into
graphite and so his company was the
largest privately owned company in like
the sixties in America but then my dad
went real deep on an oil drilling
exposition in the Amazon that didn't
quite work out so you know we grew up
you know that was wealthy as we could of
then mom was in the thoroughbred racing
in business she raised him long
she raised and she was from Cartersville
Georgia so she had a horse farm and they
raised like champion thoroughbreds and
so there's a lot of money and so I grew
up on horse racing you know I don't know
what's going on at Santa Anita these
days but twenty eight horses thirty-two
died this weekend it's like the
Dominican Republic Dominican Republic
every two days another horse dies and
somebody's having a sale on tacos in LA
there's all these new only free samples
in saying about Mary
I don't you know I was gonna I got
passes this year and after all the debts
I had a boy toilet in my heart I was
like you know what in my heart I
shouldn't give a [ __ ] about the horses
but I tell you love voices and who loved
the races my mom right she wouldn't have
gone for that [ __ ] so I ripped up two
passes that was all we always did it
once a year
yeah we want a couple times yeah always
oh is that love
but when out there in the Sun oh it's
play I can't have these you know they
had a problem when they shot that HBO
series yeah lock horses were broken I
loved died oh you liked the show oh yeah
sure was great yeah it's very realistic
but just the horses were dying they
couldn't no that's why they canceled
doctor there was a problem so
something's going on in Santa Anita
either it's the liquor cabinet it's not
good but isn't just that horses you
can't really heal them something in an
injury then you have to put them down 20
30 horses in six months I think there's
a lot of drugs and yeah basically give
them horse steroids okay and you know
they just get so big and muscular that
once they break down beyond repair which
is yeah I can't watch horse racing
anymore I good was it this kind of
animal because they're whipping the
horse to go fast yeah you know I never
really looked at it that way and the
horse don't get a dime like you know if
you make a million dollars in the horse
with you know put the penthouse yeah
you're still gonna be the $3 [ __ ]
board surrounded by mice and it will go
[Laughter]
that's where the abuse is I got a horse
that wins me a million dollars a million
dollars there there were 30,000 here I
got the horses a nice table I got him a
nice little horse that he could tie up
and [ __ ] saying like give him a freezer
filled with [ __ ] steak so we're like
I think we're like hey I'm good cheap I
don't know I I'm gonna be honest when I
was a kid I had a friend one time we
went to the Meadowlands they told me was
the state take me down there and you
talked to the trainers and I didn't like
it that's why I found out about that
drug you shoot horses if they bleed who
they know
but you shoot him with a drug so lasix
we're all calais sick so when you go on
the betting form it tells you what
horses have lasix and then pretty much
it raises their rods to win ah so I
would bet the horses on that drug to
make the bleeding stop but after I
learned all that stuff it just wasn't I
never wanted to go to the back I don't
know where you go out the back stretch
your arms there's talk to the horse and
yellow all other trainers that's not my
back like I don't want it I don't like I
don't like cooking I don't want to see
wrong me right right right I don't want
to look behind the curtain actually
enough times behind the curtain you know
and it's negligent part of me is
negligent for doing you know but at the
same time it's going to keep going no
matter how I feel people would not gonna
stop betting horses or you know and he's
not gonna stop but I just won't go to
this place because there's something
going on in this place I mean it's weird
I mean but as a kid like the first two
athletes I followed were horses or
Seattle Slew Jesus who was the 78 Triple
Crown winner and I cried when he lost he
was like undefeated and then he lost at
Santa Anita and I remember crying like
oh he's not that she best anymore and
then there was a white horse named
veigar's who his thing was dead last by
Allah he was like the white guy in the
hundred yard dash in the Olympics just
like and he would win he would just get
this bolt of energy and you there'd be
some races he was so far back you
couldn't see him in the camera shot and
then as soon as they hit the homestretch
you just saw like this white bolts of
lightning distinct it was like watching
Jordan play basketball it's the most and
then I got into hockey in the 80s but
like you know where were your mom
stables that Cartersville Georgia so how
far from the house well I grew up in
bel-air so she kept it there and uh you
know my mom was a weird person like
possibly uh
you know molested by someone and you
know her dad was killed at nine and
dad was like the Bear Bryant of Georgia
high school football coaches so you know
she was very private personally you know
she's still with us no I lost both my
parents
two months apart 98 what they leave you
I'm just kidding you a couple bucks I'm
not good I can't lie to uncle Joey and
lays an inside joke oh wait to be
offensive
please I love it when somebody's parents
just die like after a day right like
when they heart broken and they're
confused and you go up to them did you
shake them yeah you know what I love you
darling the way you know I'm very sorry
for your pain
they don't thank you for coming how was
everything else going bad and you wait
till that [ __ ] low and you know how
much isn't the well and they look
evening oh you son of a [ __ ] they laugh
right because you trying to break me I
salute
after a day - I usually catch people a
day and a half after their parents die
and I call one more if I could approach
them and that proposal I wish you around
back there and I always say them like
what did mom leave me under the mattress
and they'd look at you for a split
second Domingo you [ __ ] I knew
you're gonna make me laugh that's why
you know I love doing that to people I
love it because I remember how I felt
when my mother died oh how people would
leave the fetal ball and go Jesus Christ
I never seen so many [ __ ] in my life
other circumstances I should have
thought I shoulda said [ __ ] you they're
my family but I had a laugh because they
were honest ya know it's you know you
were very uh you know you asked me why
I'm so honest in my words in my heart
the people I was surrounded with that
when I was growing up there was no today
was get to talk to our friends we're
scared to talk to our friends we live in
a society where we are petrified
it's not like the old days when I go
Skakel come in for a second what
happened to that joke why they don't
like it well it's a [ __ ] what you liked
it was killing Thank You uncle Joey I
didn't know ya put
where it belongs I really don't like it
because my girlfriend's parents a boy it
was a [ __ ]
it's a joke you don't saying like them
people won't do that no more no there to
your close friends I really scared to
say it the ain't broke you put down some
weight hey bro I saw you had 600 kids
instead of two what you know I'm saying
we live in a society we can't do that no
more
now we need that more than ever after
Brody passed we need [ __ ] call down on
ourselves more than ever I'm not talking
about some guy from [ __ ] Tommy's
underground cafe calling out arrow
Skakel Eric Griffin I'm talking about
Tom nice tall guys go on a problem
everything you know then I left it you
were slurring you want to swear go to
your mother's house fine that's three
drinks and get the [ __ ] out of there
don't look at you a little weird for
three or four days but if they're
anything what's they usually are because
they're at the Comedy Store
don't come up do you know thank you for
telling me that that I started calling
me and that's it
you know Tom no Bonnie nobody knows
nothing we'll live in a society where
that's not accepted [ __ ] Archie
Bunker's said whatever he wanted
meathead get off my couch
stupid commies you know he used words
that we don't want to use we're living
in a petrified society and dog Joey last
time I saw you you look pretty good you
put on some weight what are you fat
shaming me mom I'm your brother I'm
telling you then you're 56 I don't want
to see you [ __ ] back yeah I mean
don't [ __ ] yourself three days later how
call you go hey Dorai got on the scale I
got to push the butter to the side I put
a little it's too much butter on the
muffin scene I'm saying yeah that's what
people do that's what you do
I saw accept it no more I pretty much
[ __ ] with people I don't say a lot of
things about ten years ago somebody came
up to me though you know your problem is
bro you're not a mentor to these young
guys that was like first I don't know
how am I to criticize somebody's act or
tell somebody what they should be doing
if you're doing something funny I'm a
[ __ ] parity
if you don't something funny I'm gonna
tell you if I see when I get to know you
and we have a mutual respect for each
other's as team mates at the store come
with it come with it Joey the army you
did that job why'd you get rid of it
sometimes I just forget it
sometimes you know that's what we have
to have especially after Brody's gone
down where they take care of each other
more at the store we're a family
look don't text me ask me how I'm doing
call me you won't hear my voice do you
want to hear my [ __ ] voice your exam
and you see somebody's little BOTS at
the store at nine o'clock pick up the
phone at once
silly sounds like that one right is he
slurring is he talking about something
stupid is he talking about a flatter me
do I need to send three Jews of the
[ __ ] flute over there you know Sam it
means so I'm happy you're part of a
comedy store family so first time you
want up we're at the store where'd you
start going on after they have the tie
resold you bum Josh I didn't know any
better like no I'm not bad you know I we
all get co-op I remember uh pledge line
the movie oh yeah Tom Hanks sells the
chick jokes that's how they meet right I
just wish she gave me 300 bucks in the
cookie jar that her husband was saving
from vacation like if they have a lot
more than she paid yes you paid him 300
he tried to get a fate and then she paid
him five and she told him [ __ ] off and
she would write her own jokes and then
one day he picked her up in a diner he
said this what the [ __ ] you do wiped
jokes that's what they want to hear they
don't want to hear that [ __ ] you're
talking about and he took her out of
Jersey it's gonna take him to the close
in New York
keep her up till 2:00 in the morning
she's killing she's killing that's a
great movie guys I love you guys are
fans of comedy please watch punchline
because I guarantee you'll see white 200
comics called an open mic the next day
Oh 400 comics didn't go online like a
guy like me you wanted the yellow pages
if you look for comedy clubs there's
four
and you called one the phone was
disconnected you called the other one
that is doing open mic and finally a
third one there's an open mic on
Tuesdays you got a call on Monday it's
three minutes and you only get one open
mic a month and yelling okay can I by
clicking you like oh my god I was
telling somebody I went to hook I never
got out of stage I get pussying out
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] enough and finally I
got my five minutes ready me in the back
of my mind this is the first time I felt
by the place this is why rule number one
don't go no way you don't blow up so so
I I read in the in the this at the time
I was a doorman at wit's end that was a
small comedy club in Westminster
Colorado a/c rule nobody big ever but
just for laughs used to release a
publication and then the publication
Johnny Walker family competition do you
remember that at all yeah Johnny would
every year leave they had for the people
at home they had a contest HBO had a
contest
Johnny walking around the country yes
and then the winner they did a a show on
CBS Wow Sharon's you were the Johnny
Walker red champion of the year you got
20 weeks a guaranteed work from The
Improv and every other Club I don't know
what they were gonna pay you but now you
were a half of a household name right so
there was the HBO one and then Johnny
Walker and Johnny Walker so I find out
about the Jerry Walker competition guess
who's going down it uncle Joey and guess
what I'm doing I'm playing I'm winning
the whole thing
that's how illusion I wasn't the cocaine
and the blow and the pills like and I
was living a normal life like I was
doing a day job and then at night I
would lose my mother come and I'd piss
in a bottle then I was I would do coke
in between the piss test I was on a
rocket ship I love it I go down to the
Comedy Works signup was at 9:00 a.m. I
get that is 45
huh Lord I sign up I go downstairs into
a basement the judges haven't showed you
half hour wait I'm looking at these guys
this guy's got an MBC shirt on
this guy's got a Late Night with David
Letterman t-shirt
this guy's got this shirt on I got so
scared I [ __ ] ripped up my [ __ ]
paperwork and left and he hadn't been on
stage yet nope chickened out so what
made you God kept going back after the
your first appearance at the spot well
the first appearance was speaking of
Brody Brody was hosting and I didn't
know what you was this is probably 99 or
2000 yes and it was the Sunday night
open mic and they'd she'd be up there
she was not up there yet at this
particular night but there was a guy on
stage from a high bomb and pretty bad
even back then it was it was bad and the
guy knew he was bombing and I he kind of
walked offstage real meekly and Brody's
like I can't do a good impression of
Brody was like where are you from kid
and the guy's like woohoo yeah Brody's
like well that drive just got a lot
longer
and that's like I don't think I'm ready
for this place and I went up and not
bombed with Tyrese I was like I think
I'm gonna open mics and stuff and come
back and I don't think I came back to
like 2009 so because I felt okay nine
years and I'm ready to be seen with at
least I thought I was at that time to be
seen with you know people who are going
up there and the lineups and I probably
wasn't even back then ready to you know
you just want to start at the Comedy
Store it's like the NBA it's a fun I'd
probably uh you know what I got passed
in 2013 and that's when I felt okay I
belong here she took your four years to
get bad yeah well 13 overall for when I
cuz Tommy and I just never collect four
which is weird because we both like the
same shitty 80s music and you know David
Lee Ross so
albums and but I just I didn't connect
with him you know so are we doing open
mics at the valley like there's a lot of
rooms in the valley I used to run mic
set of real like a speed freak bar
called McCready on Tuesday nights and
like TV comics would come in like a
Ian's bag and people of that nature but
did the improv a few times probably
wasn't ready to be honest but then you
know I'd start opening up a Rob
Schneider and that showed me the good
side of the business you know he was
very good to me
so like oh there are good people in this
business well years what would what was
making you go back night after night
what did you feel I mean I always say
you have to be delusional to think
you're gonna make it but it has to be
based in reality like you know I
probably could never play in the NBA
because I have been a vertical leap
but with comedy I've always been told
I'm funny and all my friends were agents
and managers that like I see him and
William Morris and I do just get into
comedy you're the funniest person we
know we'll help you and then they all
left again in the real estate so crazy
so but that one still is in the business
he you know makes a call for me here and
there so cuz I'm at the point now I feel
where I can't get any further on my own
you need a little Nemo phone call here
there you know so you know it's what I'm
trying to you know I'm not a great
networker schmoozer you know I'm just
pretty open honest that's not really the
best way to network yo when I go to the
Comedy Store and I see you I know I'm
not gonna hear a [ __ ] story
you sure about love yeah respect that
you either respect that watch you
sometimes that goes there one night I
was watching he made me laugh I didn't
know much about your background
who passed you and I was the first
person at me and Candace Thompson where
the first two people Adam passed how did
what was the process now then uh well
III was under a lot of pressure just cuz
everyone was going up to Adam going hey
you know Tommy really [ __ ] her all
over he's been up here for four years
you know he's really funny or whatever
they were saying and like people like
Bryan escalara were like hey Adam like
you know or I'll open for me here and
he's great you gotta pass them and like
that's the worst way to get in you know
it's like people asking you to be on
your podcast you know you don't want
people hey put a role on you
I'll put her on when I'm ready just how
this happened and so Adam just came up
to me and it's like dude I know everyone
loves you I'm gonna showcase you but if
you don't do well I can't pass you and
which I I don't want to get in through
any other way other than okay this guy
belongs so it worked out that night and
then uh it's you know but it's still
there's so much pressure at the store
and out like the lineups are crazy you
know like they're like all-star lineups
every night so I believe sponsor you get
in the way
it's an average - oh I'm not yes that's
that's two spots that two people would
give a finger for in the oh my
I mean I always remember that that I
never looked at it that way I looked at
it as [ __ ] I got a 115 spot you know
[ __ ] line never be saying something
Bryan hold from what nice he said why
are you man about because I would have
Coke in my pocket and I couldn't do it
so I got offstage so the monkey was
scratching so late I got on stage the
pisser I would get pissy or I would get
no face until one night that Holtz who
knows you know what you don't want to do
your spot don't do it put a sign out
there and say I don't want my 115 spot
70 people sign up for it and it all came
into perspective
oh yeah I mean I like this store because
Seattle you know okay I moved to Seattle
when I was doing Tommy for years two
years jerking off on myself
two years with my heart saw open mind
will every we need sleep in the car
sleep on that couch whatever gate you
got wherever we need to sleep wherever
we need to shower this is what I need I
need a sandwich a soda coffee but
besides that I'm not big you know you
pick up 75 bucks bubble pop up a bar
whatever the [ __ ] it was you moved to
Seattle to Seattle but when you moved to
Seattle it's the same thing when you
open mics around town but you have to
move into the club for a lot of the
underground and the first time Carl
looks at you checks you out knows okay I
kind of like you Lee you're gonna go
first
so for three we should go first the sex
the last two times you've been killing
and he moves you up to number five six
minutes and yeah you do about a month
and a half for that number five now
number six can't do it no more
so now he moves you up to nine and now
you've been there going for three years
but you're going up like you're not
gonna first no more you think because
you still got your job with Kinkos that
you're not making strides you're like
I'm stalling [ __ ] Kinkos but you just
moved up notches then next thing you
know you're number 12 then next thing
you know you're following the guy that's
the guest so alley one comes in you're
following that guy and they leave you
there until you get it right and once
you get it right now you start closing
the light up and now it's time for you
to son doing 30 minutes in front of that
- now you get to the store I see I've
seen you guys get to the store and start
from scratch
oh yeah and become stars I love it like
I I still get chills when I walk by and
see my name those four years what were
you thinking when you up there battling
that I mean I be honest with you at
times I thought of quitting yeah I you
know I don't know necessarily how
serious I was
because I love doing stand-up like but I
was like you know you can only be told
no so many times before you're like
cities maybe this isn't for me and I
knew as long as Tommy was there I would
never get past what tommy was there were
you getting spots there though at all no
no to be on there was nothing like that
day like he one night nobody showed up
I think Sebastian was supposed to go on
and and he didn't show up and I think
Dave my cheves was hosted and he's like
Tommy Earl's the only comic up here you
got we've got to put him up for the
show's over so he put me on and I want
to say I killed but I did pretty well
and next night they didn't show up again
it was you know and went on did well and
did nothing and Tommy's eyes you know
didn't he just I don't think he likes me
and I like puzzled still like you know
why but you know just luckily he was at
some shady accounting methods and was
fired so you know it's crazy when you
when you have a comic when you're a
comic or anything
chef and you have a dream and everything
is going right and awesome you get this
bump in the road you got some guy that's
in front of you and on top of that he
doesn't like ya for the particular
reason what a [ __ ] nightmare that is
when you get to that point he life and
he is what's holding you back the injury
and eventually you say [ __ ] you dream
when you're talking to go [ __ ] himself
and you take a different Avenue by you
doing that you get stronger
sure and three years from now you
realized that guy got fine these are the
business and you're like wow I was right
for to what I was doing because at the
end of the week it didn't really matter
I'm still here and he's not
oh yeah but it's so weird when you make
those personal decisions in your life
with a comic book er a comedy club owner
and I've lived it and seen it the guys
that would break balls there was comedy
club owners
that would break balls because this they
thought that club was the end all be all
those guys today a God God but then
there's guys at the guys Nashville right
you know the guys that run the Tampa the
Miami improv you don't Joel
they run Tempe you know those guys have
been around and they've always been
really decent and cool you know you
would you enjoy going there a week you
know you expect they know what to expect
them you know what to expect it was the
guys that would break your [ __ ] ball
the whole weekend from the minute you
got in to the minute you [ __ ] left
and what I think of those guys the
number one guy of all time rest and
peace do you little prick Danny burger
guy from Tempe right oh yeah never in my
life did I man I and I genuinely read
him it took me two years to read them
right then once I read them I left them
alone and things worked out because okay
you're a carpenter and they're building
this huge three-year building three
years when you're a carpenter straight
work that's the ability we can even be
talking about electrician we could be
talking about whatever the [ __ ] right
job for three years of stability well
the guy from the Tempe improv it's gonna
be improbable that [ __ ] guy with he
the club was great the comments were
long at dead dick sucked there was a
time where comics were going down and
coming back with their dick leakin jobs
they piss ass it's a college to him
never for me I'm never saying that it
happened to me it didn't happen to me
I'm saying that Tempe was a high family
club so they ran on
i'm danny bird of a good job that way
but he [ __ ] ruled with an iron hand
his staff failed him there was no hang
at the club afterward and if you were a
big-time headliner he'd want to hang me
so he'd already set the night of wait so
it's me you and Skakel i take you you
guys down with me our plan is to do the
[ __ ] night huh and then go to this
burger joint it'll come to you what harm
on stage and say so you guys ready to go
out you're like what are you talking
about and he'll go I got a limo outside
there waiting to take us three North
strip club Scottsdale and you know you
three look at each other you're like I
don't think that's the plan uh-huh he
would do creepy things like that then
you get on stage and he would make you
go out there with you and he got like a
VIP booth and he would start snorting
blow and I'd tell him not to do blown
from the rogue and it was horrible
right remember one day I he wouldn't pay
me because I didn't tell him well it
were all the guys were I didn't know
where their what might young was [ __ ]
Mike young we get booked and Lydell and
tell him yeah I'm gonna bring down me
another Caprio with the guys for a
garage and then he would disappear so he
thought Mike Young was at the entourage
guys and he wasn't showing up he must
have called Mike Young any time the one
that he was like if you don't call me
right back you'll never be on Letterman
you're a club alderman Tempe Arizona
that's how powerful he thought he was it
and those guys like he wouldn't let you
drink on stage right he didn't want
women in Greenville uh you know he
didn't want thousands of things that any
other improv owner you know many times
people quit at Club George Lopez put on
a Friday night what hit a weekend the
gigs booking sold-out weekend went up
there the Friday night the guy was a
known coke free God rest his soul
you know I read this Joyce Lopez looked
at yellow stage and Dan was breaking his
balls and finally in front of the older
and front everybody he was up there and
he goes how you guys doing this is a
great club I love you the general
manager holding here Dan mer just is my
impersonation of him
and he got on his hands and knees and
open the pod ha ha ha ha hold on the
thing that made believe he was doing
line of coke and his nose got all white
and Dan Baer was in the back of his wake
flew off my hands and form shot out of
Mannion oh my god and [ __ ] he [ __ ] he
got against when all you've enjoyed the
judge was [ __ ]
I quit he quit on the Friday night
option our had Wars with everybody Jesus
he threatened me and Rogin one night for
what the show was on Thursday and we
were taking the Wednesday night flight
in the one's a night flight was delayed
they pushed us on a different flight he
started calling us to see where we were
going
like where you guys had it when you get
here who knows we're going to the hotel
check-in that's it I don't [ __ ] know
well I've got reservations for four and
he don't wait what the hell maybe we
don't wanna I know Rogan didn't want to
go together then I would just laugh but
I remember that I must have shut off my
phone when I got the Tempe I belong and
I had 20 messages you better call me
back right now if not its content of
contract this shows not till Thursday at
8:00 what coming in the night earlier
just to [ __ ] come in either you know
he went off she had the last thing the
messages for jogger you gotta hear this
[ __ ] lunatic and Joe's like I'm
straightening about tonight
and we got to the hotel there he is with
some driver I made plans possibly there
Fuji the best steak in town Joe's like
knock it off we're not going there when
I technically kind of want to hang out
with you you [ __ ] creepy Joe just
went off on them and well that was it
he never bother us again how long on
your bike huh he banned me because they
[ __ ] the chicken stairs they thought
it was me what happened was a chick went
into the green room she got hammered and
she passed out we left and one of the 18
year old waiters came up and started
[ __ ] uh-huh he had never gay it was a
virginity or something like that so he
kept booking Joe but he wouldn't let Joe
break me why because he says it was me
that brought the chicken to the green
room right well reality she was there
see the star from the fear factor I mean
I'm saying hey Joe left it at least the
chick was annoying ha my saw checks are
know she fell down and [ __ ] passed
out Jesus and then now he's gone and you
can go to you do the intelligent he's
dead all right don't feel so good myself
all that drama was because of nothing
but my point being it's like when the
catcher rising stars were out here you
had to call that guy send him the tape
send them veils get a reference it was a
year process right kevin kearney that
was his name
kevin kearney he booked you in Princeton
Vegas at the Excalibur with the kids
with the swords and he booked you Reno
and all that [ __ ] and one day I got a
call from and she'll be Schubert I think
goes what are you doing tomorrow I go
nothing goes your feature for me arena I
catch a rising star so for two years
this guy drove me crazy and also the
headliner causing get you went I was
never mad at Kevin Carney after that we
became dear friends but the point being
is that comedy is very weird like that
yeah sometimes you can't get it think I
don't take your call awesome bill burr
cosmicism
with me and that's seeing the discussion
there's no tape yeah there's no [ __ ]
critique there's no nothing
have you ever noticed that oh yeah like
if you go into a club you got to send
them the tape if I bring you with me
you don't say boo you dope them away in
their nutsack top five he won't say boo
because he's gotta say something to me
and I've done the [ __ ] off yeah I mean
that's happened a lot when I was with
Schneider like who's this guy I'm the
guy whose email she didn't return for
you know two years oh you're with Rob
you want to headline an off night I'm
like oh yeah I do but it's crazy
how would I get it you evaluates you and
you get it and you have to look I'm
still there's some people and I'm in
shock that they talk to me but there's
some people who did pull for me 20 years
ago that Jeff wills
was it runs Live Nation I became friends
120 years ago
do they have a column bobbing what why
nation room can I fill up the kiddie
pond you know I'm saying what live
nation room tonight a fill and for years
I heard people go and I heard Jeff
little say nice things about it and I
would sit there no he never books me
that's how life is sometimes and your
help Jeff Wilson my number 110 Oh God
know what
I love them with all my heart because
that's how it is sometimes we cannot get
angry at anybody knows people that are
genuinely out there waiting for
something for you and then looking out
for you I knew you are going [ __ ]
Diaz probably he was going to take me
out of the Caribbean cruise little but
now I haven't heard from them or maybe
dance is working on something now and
Diaz is gonna call you and go wait what
are you doing tomorrow bro I'm taking my
girlfriend for dinner
one of the first class flight to Hawaii
and then we're going to Japan we're
getting some sushi and then we're
rolling down to the Philippines but but
but but what but what start packing tell
the Chinese to give me back that
passports Ciao Bella
leaving the property to get the [ __ ]
arm machine gun juice toting around that
no [ __ ] crowd my god why the wrong oh
yeah that's what this life is guys
that's why I always tell people keep
loose stay loose and this is not only
what are you doing August 8 I have no
[ __ ] late are you booking me for a
gig no I'm coming to town we'll call me
on the 7th I'll let you know for me it
right because you don't know what's
gonna happen
The Rolling Stones might bump into you
when you read that dog and you know
you're a comedian I thought I saw you on
YouTube yeah that was me come on the
road with us do 10 that's how quick this
could change oh absolutely
I just remember Freddy solo being at the
economy store what does their came back
Sean took him on the road they did 2,000
[ __ ] dates
what's up Revere baby he was married to
Jennifer Lopez John by the name just
left yeah
John something no I know you gotta just
let them forget the bug eyes it's Mark
Anthony Mark Anthony walked into the
comedy store Sunday night open mic so
for any on stage started talking to well
that someone became a hit who do you
think was the open Freddie that's why
yeah doing 40 minutes in front of them
in front of 2,000 20,000 people that
want to hear music want to talk about
your life flashes are funny you're up
there at the 10th minute they're booing
you Freddie used to tell me he was the
roughest time of his life but the
paycheck oh I was so good the travel the
food catering you know room service and
Mark didn't care mark was just like I
liked him yeah but one on a comedy guy
mark like that we thought he was funny
Wow I still remember being at The Improv
with Joe and Chris Maguire gettin [ __ ]
lit on cocktails I'm doing better than
that who powders the bathroom and I turn
around this Freddy soda he's like what
are you guys doing you wanna go to mark
Antony's party on this is when South
Beach was very hot
he goes I'll get it mark to send the car
for us right now and we looked at each
other like I don't think so we were I
was too [ __ ] up I couldn't show up so
we just go Freddie [ __ ] it just stay
with us and we kept Freddie out all
through [ __ ] Coconut Grove the bus
6:00 in the morning what are you nuts or
what those are the good old days
oh yeah he's I gotta leave I gotta catch
another flight to [ __ ] they would
leave a flight Peru it was crazy
it's crazy the opportunities you have at
the store you know it's like you never
know who's in the crowd watching you now
the improbability spots a little more
lately but you know I dear friends to
the page and I'm just shy and asking for
that he's a sweetheart if you just call
it four spots I can't do it I like em
all dog and shy like it's a business I
know and this is a business and you're
always a piece of a puzzle you're always
putting together a puzzle for somebody
that's why I always feel and I got mad
at leaing a very manly a couple weeks
ago because they were looking for a fat
guy to dance on that show and legal
wanted one exposed myself at 300 miles I
know it's not three houses getting your
foot in the door sure what it's it may
be an under-five on paper which means
under five lines and trust me there's
companies are scumbags hey fat man dance
you want me to dance our dance that's
350 but what if I say to you were you
from Boston do you know how to dance
yeah what type of dances do you do that
turns into 1,100 ah but you're not gonna
know till you get there because they
want to read what type of personality
you have right so what we tell them on
the store opportunities or well you're
right though no I know I'm right because
I went to do it I don't know how many
times I showed up to something and they
told me it was gonna be one thing and
don't get me wrong I got lighten to
check took eight weeks they told me 250
oh we got 175 now I had to call the guy
for the 75 hours and I had a way for the
next pay period for him to cut
check you know when you broke $75
there's a lot of [ __ ] money
[ __ ] yeah you follow me but then
somewhere along the line you going for a
co-star then that's why I always like
what they say co-star possible recurring
that means we don't know we'll look
before and so basically what I'm hearing
is at the beginning you kind of have to
do everything you do you do whatever the
[ __ ] they call you the new bride I did a
pilot you want me to be embarrassed I
did a pilot for the guys from the sign
throwing once I fell cancel they tried
to another pile Iike like a comedy
pop-up pilot
well like instead of America's Funniest
Videos videos it was funny it died right
with a host was the pilot episode there
was me getting hit in the face with a
[ __ ] pie in a diaper oh well I got
there I knew I was gonna get hit in the
face with a pie but I've know nothing
humiliated all right and I took the
humiliation I didn't like how the
producers acted obvious eight to thirty
[ __ ] days to pay me you know this is
part of it but this all that 250 or that
300 all goes into a funnel then you get
two checks up the spill for 15 a week
that's thirty five times four that's a
small one twenty right no that's a small
one sixty no it's a small one twenty
four times 30 is a small one twenty
right you know it although when you're
first doing all these things and people
always laugh at yeas Earl you making any
money and you say don't miss it all
about money right now I'm punching it
they all absolutely I'm punching it you
have an agent now I have a voiceover
agent you have a very unique voice I'm
the only white guy right now in an
all-black cartoon so but I got it at the
Comedy Store you know one night in the
crowd skinny black kids watching me had
no idea who it was
I'm making fun of him hey it's Roger
from what's happening and stupid stuff
like that and it was Tyler the Creator
and he's three seasons in on the cartoon
so it's like you know amazing like the
goes back to what you were saying you
know stores it's so much opportunity
there this was on like a Tuesday night
during roast battle I thought he was
just some black mood because I'm a
metalhead so I don't know a lot about
rappers and stuff and you know he's
amazing to me so you know little some
nice I always tell people my secret
I'm following the Skakel at 10:15 I get
there at 9:15 I say hello a waitress is
itchy Richie
the Mexicans making the potato chips the
best potato chips in the town Cobb was
coming I say hello I take my two waters
and I go onto the original I said 10 out
of 10 times it's Bobby Lee ha ha look at
Bobby Lee absorb his material for three
minutes and then I see Bobby Lee on
there first minute but what Bobby would
drive the sandy air I still remember his
dad know his brother
it's happy 20 years ago I remember going
down in doing La Jolla and he was a star
boy and Shaima Tosh couple guys with
stars in La Jolla I still am a Bobby you
know being a doorman I think opening up
for Freddie and you know so when you see
this you're like Jesus Christ not only
the like bro but these people around me
grow sir what did they do different than
the other guys they stayed the other
guys disappeared they the lost and mind
they paid they bought into the high
there's 10 guys up there I was groomed
with from Joe Rogan to Bobby
you know it's it's my body to still see
these guys then when you see them do
well your heart
Benji Avila oh yeah I saw that kid
mumble and stumble on state years ago he
goes up before me now on Saturday nights
at 9:15 I gotta think twice before I go
that I gotta think twice like I'm like
this guy is dangerous more dangerous
than Ron White little Josh that's how
smart a couple weeks ago I saw him have
the set of the year in the original so
it lets me know that that's the right
place officer
it's the rights it's like joining a
jujitsu school martial arts school you
let me get bombarded the first year at
the Comedy Store the original room is
one of the toughest rooms to call what
time do you usually go up now that the
cartoons doing so well and I I didn't
care when I went on I was so happy to be
in there I didn't care if I went on at
1:30 but now around midnight so I love
it who took the Brody spinal Holtzman I
guess is up there I mean right now he
does the main room he closes out the
main room Friday and Saturdays and
sometimes was not during the week who's
doing the midnight spot well Barris of
course closes it out every night but you
know I guess it's the newer past people
have to go on later on in the or so
Felicia goes up a couple times a week
right I think yeah what is thirty the
poor thing
that's black but that dog that one dirty
spot builds a lot of character oh it can
be pretty brutal every level of that
store builds a different muscle in you
and again it's like any other job you
get when the boss says to you go around
the building clean and make sure that
those certain things aren't that and
then one day you step on something and
it's because that thing explodes and
sure so you see the levels of everything
and that's what the store does for you
it really is a for the 68 College
Program oh and maybe even longer at the
six-year this exterior you've got the
rhythm both rooms
you're killing in the original home do
you start getting stuck
it's a tough time after six or seven
years you start to battle yourself you
know when you first get there you look
at the wall
you know why is that a Murphree not down
here every night
why isn't damon wayans not down here
every night why isn't this broad and
then well there you go oh I get it
this is another process the process is
to get out of here Jay Leno said it best
the process is to get half of the store
always go to the store but to get out
into something bigger or better and
that's what Eddie Murphy will not the
new Brier they always kept the Comedy
Store at their home at this point my
life in 56
I couldn't imagine or anywhere else to
do comedy anymore what's the best it's
the best for a guy like me right to keep
my savagery strong especially in the
original home where I gotta raise my
voice when I get offstage of the
original 30% just drops out of it I'm
wiped out that's it the week is over
yep the week is over turn out the lights
the party's over
and I love that nice to blacks to him
I'm gonna go up there and knowing I was
gonna update about following da Barrera
every time you every years I went down
there knowing I was gonna gonna have it
mom oh yeah I mean it's I killed someone
you know Saturday night
your spots it 12:30 but around 9:00 you
start calling up just to get the rhythm
of the room you're watching UFC at your
friend's house it ends at 10:00 10:30 so
you still haven't make me a spot at the
store in fact you'll be early I'll buy
some powder from Lee I'll get my pills
ready I'll get a drink and me and [ __ ]
maybe I gotta wait just you know see if
she you're a little blaster coke to get
a following me around can I get more hot
for the spot or never checked out won't
get out of here oh I had a thousand
methods up there and what we talked
about just about the store
don't you reach up like Irish and oh you
said you do reach a level there and you
never get comfortable you get frustrated
oh yeah I got very frustrated by 2004 I
was very frustrated
in my personal career because I was
killing at the store but nothing was
happening it's tough you feel like oh
that's how I feel right now I mean now
some things are happening but you know
it's you always want more I think you
know doing the road work at all well now
I can because I have credits but before
no one would feature or headline me
because I won't do we just can't bring
you up as hey he's a funny guy but now
you know what the cartoon and you know
I'm dying up here and you know roast
battle I'm pretty popular on that show
so yeah I'd love doing the road you know
because I love comedy I'm not in this
business to be famous or to make money
you know I realize it's a side effect of
the business but I just love performing
I got a sexual high drama I've seen the
people who have gotten into it for money
they give up first it's the people will
fall in love with him no you know what
this is what I want to do yeah I mean a
few minutes it's gonna take nine years
but to take nine months but I'm gonna
die trying I can't imagine being 50 for
medium situation in your life you're not
starving you're paying your bills you
put a little money away you have credit
card debt like the rest of America and
you look at your life here's me you know
I did okay but I really wanted to be a
guitar player I wish I would have tried
one time you know I know I'm never gonna
have that fear maybe I could have been
an attorney I'll hang up for Valley
College tomorrow and go on the road ten
we see and doing a podcast go to school
or law school you know yeah for me I
think it's too late I'm 56
I'm good there's nothing I want to do
then I want to try I don't want to go
over the seas I don't want to see China
I don't know
shit's gonna get ugly pretty soon over
there I'll pass
real fast you feel you're happy is this
what you want to do oh absolutely
you're my age where you're 50 now and
you're 57 are you gonna look at the
mirror one day and said you know what it
really doesn't matter what ended up
happening I still did what my dream was
since the fourth grade oh absolutely I
mean the only thing I regret is not
starting earlier cuz I started at 30 so
I mean I started at 18 I started at like
[ __ ] 29 28 well yeah that's the only
thing where I'm like yeah you know I
wish I maybe was started but what would
you have to talk about at 21 not much
but I don't I I just you know 27 you've
been hard you have you found art break I
don't go has died a parent has died
you've lost a cat your girlfriend
cheated on you with the neighbor some
other girl gave me gonorrhea you had
experience at 27 you know I'm saying you
have $60,000 in debt and student loans
you're looking at a life a little
different than 21 I like people who have
gone on stage while they were in college
I have nothing against that I really
don't I have more power to they got
their feet wet earlier but I think they
really found their voice once you got to
pay your own bills is when you start
finding your real voice and I may be
wrong oh no I don't know but I just wish
maybe maybe just a little earlier no I'm
perfect when I did it when I did it I'm
perfect I have no [ __ ] regrets I
started 28 I got serious about it 30
rock 30 I'm like okay if this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna pull up our
[ __ ] sleeves I get it I get the work
back this [ __ ] I've been doing for the
last two years again on stage every two
weeks and telling people I'm a comic
that that's I'm a [ __ ] all right you
gotta do this 18 times a night and you
know put your [ __ ] glasses on and go
deep oh yeah you know the deeper the
better I mean I've always had that work
ethic but uh I guess now it's trying to
navigate the other side of the business
you know the networking I like to call
it Paul
you know hey how are ya brother the
networking is on stage as a comic if I'm
an agent and you come up to me and said
Oh Skakel comedian I go Jody and CAA
how's it going trying to put my career
together are you on the one up tonight
no then why the [ __ ] are you here right
that's always been my opinion don't go
no way you don't belong what if I gonna
have to see Chris D'Elia I walk in the
room I get settled I sit I catch my hair
and I look up on a CEO staple and I
approach oh my god yeah it's um it's
interesting for me to listen you guys
talk about this stuff because Fernet
like I take it seriously but I don't
even think I'm really in the business of
staying idea it's still just it's more
than a hobby but I'm for me getting paid
as a bonus so it's good it's interesting
to hear you guys talking about when I
like when you guys when you basically go
pro at it and how you have to figure out
how to get paid how to get howhow turned
into more than just something you enjoy
doing I'm just uncomfortable promoting
myself like even this weekend the
cluster fest I had a ICM agent asked me
about the cartoon and I was almost
embarrassed I know it's it's going okay
you know it's going good you know I'm
not I just I wish I could talk myself up
a little more because I think to get to
that next next level of you and Rogan
and Julia you've got a cell from a lot
more yeah I have a problem with that too
and I think a lot of I hear a lot of
people say they have problems with it
but and you don't want to be the guy who
who over does it but I think I think you
don't want to wish you had done ever or
you can't get no one's gonna do it for
you there's too many people here yeah I
mean you have to do it yourself
cuz you know there's ten other people
who will do it for themselves right
good-looking look at it as letting the
guy know what you're doing
and letting that person know what you're
looking at right without
don't come up to me say hi hello skate
oh yeah you look where you're funny
throw anything else gonna learn your
life you know my film just took second
place in the Chicago Film Festival
that's all I say good night later you
know so I rather you say to me yeah I'm
working on the one man show about my
wife she got hit by a motorcycle in the
head when she was walking you know I'd
rather you tell me about your future but
and let me know what you're doing a
little basis not you're throwing at me
right right I know I've been fortunately
enough lately I will book a lot of stuff
but I booked this cartoon and to be
honest here it's black so I'm very lucky
there they gave me the second season
you're not boasting you're letting me
know number one you're an earner yeah I
don't listen I don't give a [ __ ] if you
got a voice to Sinatra and you can bend
over at the same time cliff Roman kanva
love you [ __ ] oh wow is that that's
quite a shame if that would be a good
show if you can't sell tickets
I really don't have any interest in you
I learned a long time ago I get calls I
tell me every three days from an old
acquaintance from town that's found out
the podcast is doing well I'm getting
more spots or whatever and they'll try
to sound we had a project they have and
that was me 15 years ago people come to
me in a sack of pitch and I would come
up with something that we'd pitch and
the people say thank you for coming in
because the guy was with was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and the whole thing stuck but
that's not it even if I walked in there
when I Love Lucy I was a nobody
and people don't want to do business at
nobody's I don't know Pelham you have a
[ __ ] we have the next American Idol I
don't give a [ __ ] if you have the next
American family it's very weird how this
town works if you have a little bit of
heat in the old days they threw it under
fifty thousand to hold you for you to
see what you're gonna do with that more
and you put a rider together can people
to pitch together what shows do you have
in mind what up what's Episode seven
gonna be about what's episode nine gonna
be
but you really think you could do that
be here not really
you tell you come up with a half [ __ ]
the idea and then with the idea doesn't
work
guess whose fault it is and so now when
CBS goes we're looking for new guy Lee
comes in and says oh my god
I seem to cutest white guy isn't he was
an all Skakel did he ever show on NBC
yeah next you this is a very weird town
they want to do business with you on the
way up they don't want to do business
with you want the way down all right no
book in The Longest Yard trying to get a
radio show guys name was boom ba Johnny
back in New Jersey
ah big [ __ ] radio show he did a year
of time cuz he was shaking down the
girls at Dolly's place I remember call
the visit man and pick up I met him on
the show he got into comedy not the best
comedian but because of the radio show
he was really pick up the [ __ ] the
show and he would do these shows they
invited me to do a show and he gave me
his number
like no Hamblin reading this movie I
like to someone to promote it and I
called him he was a Jersey guy so I
don't we got a common bond and when I
call it out I never got mad it just made
me understand where I stood when I call
the mikoshi and listen I talked to the
producers and it's not a good idea
the bottom line is willing business and
making stars you have to be a star to
come on the radio show me really a dia
Bon Jovi call many people like that I
didn't hang up on him I understood what
that meant and it was the truth I don't
give a [ __ ] of you and him over on the
sale there's 80 other people in that
movie home when you're Adam Sandler
all right you know then they hurt my
feelings for three seconds then you
understand the business side of it sure
because no man in this comedy [ __ ] as we
learned now you're at the candy store
oh I'm sorry you know doesn't never gets
old see right now we gotta take it to
the next level let's not charge so how
many of you do comedy I'll say 20 20 and
now you're gonna take it to the next
level
and let me tell you something you can't
you know how I know because I took it to
the next level at the 16th year right
18th year maybe the 20th year 19th year
was where you figure it out and now
people call me can you give it do you
want to come in with an idea 20 years
ago you won't call me house the same
time right it's doing the same one she
jokes the same one she [ __ ] material
you know I've you know many times I've
seen we come in with no management no
agency and do a set two days later
see you come in with two Jews the black
guy everybody's got a suit on one black
guy's got a hammock on Jews don't have a
yarmulke but the black guys got a
hammock on and you're doing exactly the
same jokes isn't we pretty much in the
same vein and CBS is coming to see you
you you're in town for a meeting with
Robin Williams it's a state you know
I've seen it a thousand times we never
know what's gonna work it's not up to us
the only thing with its control is our
growth our writing and never to stop
doing what we believe in also and what
we think we can aspire to me I don't
want to know it you only wanna ban it I
want you to keep that to yourself and
every day you know you go you see
somebody you're gonna watch someday I'm
gonna be as good as Sebastian I'm gonna
go how come I couldn't be the Liat you
know many times I was job I may be a
jerk-off alone myself I throw it in my
face
why couldn't it be job away you gotta
figure out who skate Louis yeah I mean
Louie say it has to figure out who we
say Attis little quicker you figure the
stage without a portray it to the
audience
the quicker this party starts but I see
a lot here it's been warm guy there are
negative energy out of the year how was
this festival this weekend it's fun I
did Ross battle it was a tough battle
just cuz I had to battle of transgender
comic in San Francisco
definitely an away game but I got to do
Todd Barry's crowd work show which was
super fun
you got a website and stuff like that no
just Twitter and Instagram
Earl Skakel and what does your podcast
get release usually every Tuesday it's
just called inappropriate Earl and my
last name which is kind of weird as just
spelled ska ke l I got a hard time
saying it's like a [ __ ] tongue
twister yeah I mean it's I get skank old
skunk Alaska Kel every time I'm saying
it I think I'm saying it wrong that's
what the sound like skanky yeah I mean
it's like skanky cousin Skakel yeah it's
when you go to the hospital and your leg
has finally fall off and they're like do
I have
whatever though you got cankle yeah
whatever the [ __ ] girls giggle you had a
cankle I mean ask a call so how was your
experience in whatever first Oh skank
fest New York was awesome
New York was my first time being there
and doing comedy and it uh it was just
amazing it was I did 11 spots in four
days not all of them went great
I'm kind of bummed about that but I got
to do show I got to do a whole bunch of
clubs and rooms and thank you to Felipe
and Louis J Gomez and everybody I you
know it was kind of a glimpse ahead to
see like what what this could be if I
keep going and it showed me how much I
loved New York and and I got to like
like Quentin the host at Dangerfield was
great to me
everyone was great it like it's um
sometimes you hear about some negative
stuff about comedians and comedy this
was an overall an amazing weekend I got
what you guys are talking about we'll
see what happens but I got I got off
stage at a small club the Broadway
comedy club and this guy was like oh I'm
an agent here's my card
are you sag and I'm not anything so that
was amazing I had one of the best sets
of my year-and-a-half the midnight show
it's gang fest so I I couldn't be
happier
that's great ideally there's a lot of
fun you know and I'm like the old guy in
comedy and I'm seeing all this
we don't sitting now looking at all you
guys going oh that guy just got on the
rotation belt all this is a rotation
well you're like a Keebler ahmud cookie
they put you on the belt and you let
piece of dough with three M&Ms and a
piece of Harmon and then depending on
how long you go to the oven that no
offense Lee that's how quick I dare you
that's how quick you [ __ ] stay but
before you hit that if you say I'm gonna
jump off the [ __ ] belt
get him saying yeah so I mean at the
time you still give me a getting it the
rotation at the improv games are
rotation at the Laugh Factory
you know you placed on a rotation belt
and take to the factory being three
[ __ ] miles away and it's a [ __ ]
double your processing that cave of
developing and forming and now let's see
how fast convey about it's all up to you
and it's this is such a great life that
we live I love it because no matter what
art what career you pick you pick it you
put your head down
you're gonna eat [ __ ] no matter what you
do when you're adopted what do you think
you walk in then they give you a like
it's tv2 guys put the gloves on you and
they give you a citizen you ain't giving
all this done you're cleaning our guts
you're washing people's nutsack
you're jerking people off so they don't
have a heart attack what hospital these
guys don't know buy you have a mix of it
you sponsor you how did something it's
not like a porn I've seen before
but anyway skate Club I'm happy I wanted
you're always on the podcast to come in
and talk about yourself
I don't we went off on some tangents I'm
sorry next time okay yeah oh we could
talk about Miami Vice the whole except
song like Miami Vice was a masterpiece
well the first three seasons were
actually kind of dark like it gets most
of the publicity for the music and the
clothes and like every episode look like
a music video
but if you break down the characters you
know Crockett was a you know a Dark Soul
you know Tubbs was always looking for
Calderon and revenge and swai tech would
had a gambling problem and you know so
it wasn't just a a fluff show that check
Gina
fell from the Father from taking yeah he
brought the weapons from the IRA and
then didn't believe and that was a very
good episode Ted Nugent was a very good
episode when he was lured drug dealers
he would send the check out to the beach
and she would fall in love with him and
she'd make him shall come back with a
black eye Ted Nugent was [ __ ] walk
around with no shirt on and he would say
so tell me about the guy and she would
say he's cute I think he's got the money
then he goes you ready to work and when
he was open up with him smacking her in
the face then she would run to Carl's
kcon though Joey beat me we gotta get
away from him but I'm scared
I know he's got a gun that eight kilos
of coke and I know he needs to sell it
and she would know that her own skate
was in the business so she would set you
up you met him out in the desert a
construction site he'd get out of the
car blast you and then bury on the dirt
and he had tons of bodies out there I
was a stranger he would take the money
from me and go to his car shoot him
pull away and then bury you it was a
tremendous episode another great episode
Frank Zappa yeah on the boat I don't
know who he was working for you know
that's how they by Tuesday they were a
great marketing machine because by
Tuesday they'd show you who was gonna be
on on Friday your whole week was planned
around there all right a night I didn't
leave the house so I still remember the
different
it's the pilot two hours and then the
first episode opens up with a Colombian
guy getting a drink of water you see the
water pouring into the glass and also
before he goes to drink it a guy smacks
the glass out of his hand and says tell
me who the [ __ ] he is
I don't know they call the Argentinian
he's got a hit list
all right and also you see croc in the
tubs in that boat just going out for the
Bahamas that's how the first Apple
father is and they go down there he
falls in love with Calderon his daughter
yeah and he knocks around and they shoot
Calderon episode one two or three
no it had to be like Episode four or
five there was a little yeah they shoot
Calderon they get calendar and all they
come back and then season three that's
my favorite citizen is when Crockett and
Tubbs go to a diner then Crockett has
the Tubbs has to make a call and a
carpool yes they put two guns to his
head they put him in a van they take him
away and he walks into a house it's
gorgeous
but it's a chick that comes out it's a
chick he had the affair with child
around his daughter and no she's got a
kid but she's got a brother who's played
by John Leguizamo 1987 it's 2019 John
Leguizamo 1980 play seven played
Calderon Sun tremendous episode are
there's so many good ones remain this
episode and next thing you know how
their own takes the kid and ties the
sister up in a Cadillac there's an f-117
yes well you know now it's on I just
bought all five seasons I think it's on
Amazon Prime or Hulu or Amazon put him
it they put the baby in the car with the
sister and I were surrounded by dynamite
and when they attack they blow up the
baby and the [ __ ] thing but before
that whole scene goes down who was the
guy that popped into the scene he was a
commissioner Lee Iacocca this is how
strong the show is the president of
[ __ ] Chrysler is on this episode and
people went nuts
he played like this [ __ ] crazy guy
yeah I love to check it out like yeah go
in there and bomb up it's a free zone I
don't care what you do so when they
bobble they bomb them they think
Calderon is dead they go through the
rubbage they find paperwork they do this
whole thing they showed Tubbs depressed
and the episode ends with them being in
a funeral parlor they're outside they're
burying the sister and the baby
everybody's dead and a flower truck
pulls up late and puts his stand up and
when Tubbs takes the [ __ ] thing off
it he opens it up and it sort of her
hearing and it says I'll be back that's
how the season I mean this was they were
[ __ ] with the insides so dark it a
darkish episode Tonio mano
that was the funny or cairo Tony or
Carroll was the guy that's still around
that they buried him in the wall yeah
they buried him in the wall bruce mcgill
and a cop had a nervous breakdown
and he kept saying that he knew what
tony on carol was know why he was dead
and finally he took them to the thing
yeah but they up and the dire straits
saw the yes the dies to whatever the
name at all that's a great song yeah
it's very haunting but and the guy who
was his partner rhymes david Strathearn
yes he's in the new Godzilla movie I
mean yes but you go over but I'm talking
about it was a guy's name was Tony Amato
Tony hamana was played by Bruce Willis
he Paul cat he played an episode as a
guns dealer that beat his wife Cubs got
involved Crockett got involved with the
wife and at the end in his bodyguard was
another guy from the Konami store he's
banned from the Comedy Store as there
was Vinny Colonel oh wow I'm punch dice
in the face they call Mitzi a [ __ ] oh
the good old something the dice either
smacked dice he did sir any colonel was
almost a world champion
he could've fought [ __ ] the guy from
Boston
let movie know whatever is damaged
atacama guy from Boston who brought the
mess all right
Haiti's the toughest guy part not Marvin
Hagler yes he could have fought him he
was up next to fight him I mean I was at
ex-cop guy myself
yeah he played I think Tex Cobb was on
Miami Vice too yes well uh so would
[ __ ] now with when they kill flight
actin yeah but my favorite ever from
Miami Vice was a guy by the name of
Charlie Barnet I was just on my parents
graves I was just gonna say my favorite
episodes are the ones with Charlie
Barnet and martin ferrero is he and the
nug man let the noogie boogie let the
lily boogie will mr. Calderon maybe in
that familiar of mr. Calderon style
maybe you're not familiar mr. Dogman
style mr. Doug man was Dave Chappelle's
meant yeah he opened up Dave would open
up for him Washington Square Park he
auditioned for San I arrived he got it
but there was a problem he couldn't read
him so they gave the role to Eddie
Murphy instead so any Murphy was born
and Charlie born that's not being able
to read but everybody respected when
Charlie Barnet was on Miami Vice they
would basically call and go come down
and just read her a lot Oh him an S he
had such great chemistry heaven is e
with tremendous yeah I just watched the
one before Chon came on about the
Pirates Omaha was nothing the college
one kids that became pirates and is he
handsome enough he's young at the white
girl you gotta go underneath and all
this stuff and he died of HIV yeah but
he was great DC cab yeah what the
barbarian brother yes
barbarian brothers David and Peter Paul
36 eggs a day they we don't do steroids
we just keep dirty sick things of that
Jesus I worked out once next to them at
Gold's Gym in Venice no you did yeah I
mean I where are they today you know
where they are
I would guess out here yeah probably
colds Jim in Venice they were throwing
weights at each other
what and I mean like 40 pound dumbbells
like it was a baseball I was like wow
it's like roid rage so you know but yeah
DC cab bill Mahr Gary Busey Adam Baldwin
it was like a t yeah uh was he a DC cab
yeah look at uh mr. t max the guy from
Barney Miller a bald guy and Max Baer I
think great cast
I saw Bill Maher once at the store and
you know I'm sure he's used to people
hey I love you on politically incorrect
and I just looked at him like DC cab bro
and you liked it I don't bring that up
it's a great movie mr. t is DC cab he's
on he's on the cover
oh wow yeah it's been a hot minute since
I've seen it but you know I'm much more
familiar with Miami Vice you know I like
that you're a student of the game I like
that you really astute another game in
the one in the old-time shows I have
some meetings the next couple of weeks
and they're very loose meetings I'm
going into the VP's and we'll have a
talk with them and it's very loose
beings until I was doing something oh
what do you tell these people what do
you tell people what's wrong with
television you know and my big thing is
to let him know that when I came to this
country
TV was my everything surely everything
was in television emotions how to act
how to speak different things and the
show's had more heart room 222 oh my God
Squad
Mission Impossible was just a brilliant
show that why they can't remain it
perfectly baffles me I would I wanted to
pitch that show the last four years then
the first guy I would take is Jack's and
Sons of Anarchy well Charlie Hunnam he's
an English guy with an English accent
white people love all that [ __ ] he's the
lead he's hot
give him a female lead and
the three that nobody's ever seen before
see keep that scale give Charlie Hunnam
Charlie Hunnam 17050 in episode I don't
get it he got FX he'll get it on CBS so
you gotta pay his [ __ ] toll he's with
CAA so that was the Mission Impossible
and do it the same way it's 2019
obviously you can't get a tape recorder
and you can't get a [ __ ] phone but
you could sit down there's a cell phone
then you open it up and you press the
button it's Lisa I act on mr. Diaz good
morning
yeah it's Tuesday April 26 today we're
looking at a guy named Harold Skakel
international gun smuggler we want you
to go with building get us to proof and
don't get any agents kill the safe will
self-destruct in 30 seconds and they
will put the phone down or some smoke
starts coming out of it also you hear
that your head would go [ __ ] crazy
they've never done that but even if they
do get it they would miss something they
would try to add comedy to it or add a
love story to it go with the original
recipe but number one don't lose the
patois of the show well I think it's
like like I'm a huge bad news bears
right the first well I need the 7 the
Golden Arrow TV was those 700 or so ones
that really broke through with the
Jeffersons the good times the sample ins
you need to go back to that blueprint
what television is never gonna be able
to compete with streaming but I don't
think you can because like if you like
the Bad News Bears to me is a perfect
example of the original one none of
those kids were actors they were kids
and in the remake with Billy Bob
Thornton they were clearly kids all
right we need a good-looking kid to play
Tanner Boyle and you know we need the
fat catcher but that fat catcher and the
original one you can tell he's just a
fat kid with no acting ability it was
great I can making up a transgender can
all watch out how funny would that be
that's 2019 now he's not a fat kid he's
a black kid that one stuff that
identifies as a female anyone
is right I mean coach has to look at you
go but your name is Charlie yeah but my
name is really Irene I mean that's it's
coming to character I didn't see maybe
it could work
listen man you just got to do something
with T because it's not compete with
what the [ __ ] is going on
I just don't dreamy everybody has a
different show they're watching
congratulations to Gabriel vases yes
Netflix series mr. Iglesias I haven't
watched it yet but I have flight this
week and that's all the girl Skakel
thank you very much for coming on don't
forget you have any dates coming up
anywhere on this game just a cartoon on
Adult Swim right now what something a
cartoon it's called the jellies by Tyler
the Creator and you but I just I mean
this from the bottom my heart and then
some of your fans may think of this as
ass kissing I'm a horrible ass kisser
but if everyone and comedy were like you
be a lot easier business to navigate
with trillion brother we're trying to
convert a young so when they get at that
point they note again I get off with the
light comes on they don't to be
respectful and most of all they're
[ __ ] savages because that's what I
need you to be [ __ ] all that
Christianity I need you throw away the
cross and like the Bible on fly if you
want to be a convict there's no rules
[ __ ] there's no borders
I want to thank their old Skakel don't
forget Friday and Saturday Saturday is
already sold out Columbus the funny bone
I'm coming in [ __ ] I'm doing a
little Muay Thai on Saturday morning I'm
gonna get some [ __ ] lunch in town and
that's it and that's that the funny bone
go for tickets right now and then July
5th we had an extra show at the rec room
in Huntington Beach so July 5th the 4th
you sit there you'll watch firecrackers
you're hanging out with Chinese people
come see uncle Joey all right I love you
[ __ ] one more time for else
cackle one more time for Milan Easley
Sian and now for a word from our
sponsors all right I want to thank my
main man
Skakel I want to thank the flying Juba
most importantly I want to thank you
guys listen as most of you have found
out the hard way getting into debt is
easy getting out of debt is hard
especially if your FICO score isn't
great thankfully now this upstart com
the revolutionary lending platform that
knows you're more than just a credit
score and office you're smarter into
rate interest rates that help you pay
off your high interest credit card debt
upstart goes beyond the traditional FICO
score when assessing your
creditworthiness they actually reward
you based on your education and your job
history in the form of a small smarter
interest rate upstart believes you're
more than just a credit card score right
they believe in you and they understand
that they make it fast simple and easy
to check your rate in just a few minutes
without affecting your credit card score
the best part once the loan is approved
most people get their funds the very
next day are you listening to me the
very next day over 200,000 people have
used up up start to pay off credit cards
student loans
fund their weddings or to make large
purchases free yourself from the burden
of high interest credit card debt
why consolidate and everything into one
monthly payment would up start listen to
me I got into debt I wish I would have
had an upstart then one payment you get
your credit FICO score back up there and
now you're ready Iraq see why upstart is
ranked number one in that category with
over 300 businesses on trust violet and
Harry table Starcom slash Church CH you
are CH to find out how low your on star
train is checking your rate only takes a
few minutes and it will not affect your
credit that's upstart com slash Church I
will also talk to you people about CBD
listen if you go into a liquor store and
you buy a bottle of vodka and you get
CBD all you're probably drinking like
snake juice or some [ __ ] alright lucky
for you [ __ ] I found
CBD line they may see we people to a
product and start to finish
CBD line has you covered you want to
smoke the vape pen smoke the vape pen
you want to smoke the cartridges you
want to smoke the shadow oh you're not
in to smoke them pardon the [ __ ] out of
me
they got gummy bears that'll make your
[ __ ] go up and down and the tensions
forget about it you put two blasts under
your tongue you [ __ ] start speaking
in tongues their products are clean
Bobby and they aren't like the fakes
that with the false advertising go to
CBD line comm and check out their third
party lab results I dare you go ahead go
you're gonna be [ __ ] amazed and right
now today the church gets 20% off at
checkout
when you go to CBD line calm checkout
Church CH you are CH that's how we do it
here it's summertime you got the car you
got the shiny snakeskin shoes you got
the sunglasses like Johnny Ola Bamba but
you got a watch that looks like your
grandfather gave it to you like
Christopher Walken took it out of his
butt and pulp fiction or something like
that then you wonder why you're a motive
on listen a wristwatch is a personal
style statement and I'm no Johnny GQ you
elevate your game with Vince arrows
handcrafted watches available at an
unbelievable price I got a beautiful
platinum on right now look at this thing
stay beautiful tells me the time it's
always not no problems a year not a
problem I use it on stage it's falling
off and it's still rocking and rolling
all right that's why I like Vince arrows
they provide bold timepieces always
putting quality above all else whether
you're looking to make a statement or on
a staple piece then sarah has no watch
for you if you want to change it up all
the resale watchbands are
interchangeable
Vince arrow offers the best value in the
industry with exceptional craftsmanship
you can't pay for that then several
exceeds expectations
style and quality with over 16,000
16,000 five-star reviews I don't know
nobody who gets that many five-star
reviews
so get your visera watch today not
tomorrow grab a pen I will offer the
church family 15% off at checkout that's
right with free shipping worldwide
cordovan sarah watches calm and the coat
church grab a pen CH you are CH at
checkout for 15% off your order and
worldwide shipping is always free
that's for Sarah watches comm promo code
Church and I'm wearing one as we speak
and I got another one at the house in
the box ready to throw down when I got a
little premier or some because that's
how I roll I want to thank with several
watches
I want to thank CBB lion calm and most
importantly I want to thank upstart get
your life together it all starts will up
start I want to thank my Manito Skakel I
want to thank the flying Jew but I want
to thank you [ __ ] I'll see you
this weekend Columbus Ohio funny bone
Columbus funny bone calm there's only
tickets for Friday available do what you
gotta do I love you [ __ ] to see
you Thursday and at least I am